we have this from timcast.com breaking
the pat Pelosi body camera footage
released and oh boy do I have a lot of
questions that need to be answered
because you know we were hearing a lot
about what happened with Paul Pelosi's
attack we had a lot of questions about
what seemed to not make sense
the video seems to clarify a lot of what
we didn't know but oh boy does it raise
a whole lot of questions about what was
going on and uh look I don't know what
happened all I know is it's a very very
weird very weird video now I do want to
say
earlier today I did a segment where I
talked about how I thought it was more
likely it was a drug deal gone wrong
it makes more sense but then they did
release the footage showing to perhaps
smashing the back back door window yeah
and now I'm like okay I'm gonna walk
that back still think it's possible but
probably very unlikely because it would
require them staging a broken window for
some reason which I don't know maybe
they did but I really find it unlikely
I'll just tell you this in the video
footage you can see this right here I
got questions
how is it that
Paul Pelosi in his underwear is holding
a drink of some sort
and the hammer into Pap's hand
and they're both at the door with the
police and and Paul Pelosi does not walk
out to the police he just stands there
looking in a stupor you look at his face
and he's like huh he could run to them
right there they're right there why
doesn't he just run to them because the
Pap's got the hammer and and Paul is
trying to stop is hold it because when
they say hey drop the hammer the pap
responds you let go of that handle like
so he's the cops pulling on the hammer
you let go he falls back run just run to
the cops you they're right there but I
did I think they're hammered I think I
think Paul Pelosi is drunk out of his
mind which is part of why they didn't
want to release it because he's in his
boxers drunk and one in the morning with
his drug dealer whoever this guy is I
mean he's in his own home to be fair to
Paul it's his home if he wants to be
drunk in his boxers do anything wrong I
wish they had really I don't blame him
for being a raging alcohol 82 years old
mayor Denise
well it's the stock trading that really
bothers me that his wife gives him
inside deals allegedly hold on hold on
we did not excuse that we excused the
drinking right right so go and drink it
go on with your bad self Paul but uh lay
off the stock trades I think I think the
reason isn't run to the cops he's
plastered he's just drunk out of his
mind trying to stay calm that's why so
he just gets drunk every night and this
happens
yeah so here's what I here's what I
think I'd kill someone in that DUI too
no he injured someone he hit another car
oh really yeah yeah he didn't just like
get a DUI and go on like he hit another
car I can't remember if the if it was
fatal or no he's a drunk I think the guy
breaks in Paul probably already had a
drink was probably just blasted out of
his mind to perhaps like where's Nancy
and he's like
wow you know just like and then he calls
9-1-1 you got to listen to this 9-1-1
call I haven't heard it it does not make
sense yeah it doesn't
people have said
he's trying to de-escalate a crazy man
breaks into your house you don't want to
get into a fight with him you want to
talk him down try and get the police
there there's that old story where the
woman is being abused by her boyfriend
so she calls 9-1-1 and pretends like
she's ordering her pizza and she's like
I'll have a large pepperoni and the
dispatcher's like man this is 9-1-1 and
she goes yes yes
ma'am you can't order pizza here and
she's like yes a large pepperoni ma'am
are you saying this because someone is
around you who will hurt you yeah and
they go okay what's your address and
then they give the address and make it
seem like it's a pizza but Paul Posey
wasn't doing that he's like I think I
called you by mistake and then she's
like do you need emergency emergency
services he goes no
uh what do you think and then the pap
goes I think it's good and she goes and
he goes okay what happens on the tape
yeah yes hear him sitting with him and
he's or standing with I thought he was
in the bathroom I thought he was like a
bath nope originally and he's like he's
like she's like do you need emergency
fire or medical and he goes I don't
think so I don't think so
um what do you think and then the pap
goes I think we're good and he goes he
says he thinks we're good but
um but he's not leaving and I'm just
like oh hold on a minute okay so that's
kind of like a hostage call isn't there
a moment where Paul is like why would
the pat be like it is totally fine
you've called the police and I'm
standing here talking with you and I'm
your friend the pap even says I'm a
friend yeah but Paul has to ask him his
name she's like what's the guy's name
and sure we hear David dipapco David I
mean like I don't know that they
actually know he's not saying he did I'm
just saying this sure they didn't know
he doesn't maybe the guy's not his
dealer I had that narrative going on in
my head maybe he's just some Miranda no
no for sure for sure but my question is
then why would depap let Pelosi call
9-1-1
communicate with the dispatcher and
Pelosi maybe he said he was calling
Nancy
San Francisco PD
should be feeding
oh wait three yeah
it's a San Francisco police do you need
help
oh what is a Hillman uh here just
waiting for my wife to come back
zero okay do you need to please fire a
medical for anything eight seconds uh I
I don't think so I don't think so
zero two twenty three and probably eight
seconds yeah the the uh
um
is the Capitol Police around 220.
my wife they usually hear it they're
usually here at the house protecting my
wife uh no this is San Francisco police
Friday October I I no I understand
um
okay well zero uh
uh
it means everything's good I I've got a
problem but he thinks everything's good
okay hold on real quick I've got a
okay maybe it's fair to say he is trying
to de-escalate and he's scared to say
please send police but he literally
asked for the Capitol Police that
doesn't make sense saying that they're
they're usually protecting his wife
maybe he wanted to make the Papi feel
more at ease to know the there's no cops
around but he could have been like oh I
can call them and tell them to bring
Nancy I'll call him right now well how
did how did the pap let him call 9-1-1
he denies wanting emergency medical but
then literally I'm sorry Emergency
Services police or fire but then asks if
the capital police are around I think
that it sounds like he was making a
phone call to I bet he just tried to
appease him and said uh oh we'll get
Nancy oh you want Nancy I'll get Nancy
on the phone right now and he makes a
call and he's talking about I called you
by mistake yeah because you would if you
were to Pappy you would not know he was
talking to 9-1-1 there it makes me think
he called the Capitol Police or his
whoever it secures his house normally
first and didn't get a hold of them
because he then is like I must have
called you by mistake because I'm
actually looking for someone else our
Capital police around like he doesn't
actually want to be talking to San
Francisco police he wants to be talking
to cattle police if they think he
actually called by mistake don't you
have a contact for them I think I think
he I think Paul was drunk out of his
mind and called them by mistake I don't
know for sure but think about this if
the pap was gonna let him make a phone
call why wouldn't he call his wife or
the Capitol Police maybe that's what he
said he was doing we don't know what
he's no no hold on de pep let him call
the police but the pap know he was
talking to police he's literally talking
to someone who says do you want police
but is he on speakerphone
not on speakerphone why didn't he say
yes send the police I probably because
he the pap was standing there with a
hammer like three feet away okay okay
we gotta pause real quick I'm pulling a
pizza he's on the phone and they say do
you need police fire medical no I don't
think so because the package at him can
so then why did he say are the capital
police around yeah that's interesting
well you're not going to make the guy
feel more at ease he called the Capitol
Police because he's waiting
messing with the drunk logic is no logic
yes yes yes maybe maybe
look I'm sorry
let him make a phone call or he made a
phone call and the Pat was getting angry
but if he's concerned if he was doing
the secret thing where he's like please
send me a pizza when the when if the pep
can't hear and she says do you need
police he could have he could have been
like oh yeah yeah that'd be that'd be
great but maybe can hear but then he
literally says there's a capital police
around to perhaps certainly heard that
yeah and if he was concerned if if he
was concerned about perhaps reaction
why did he call sfpd
ask for the capital place instead and
say he doesn't want sfpd when he could
have taken his phone and called drunk
logic is no logic he was I think it's
possible because this doesn't make sense
he was so drunk he accidentally called
sfpd because he's got sfpd and capital
placed in his phone and he's like he
hits the wrong button look there's a
million reasons he could have done this
but when I heard this
everyone's saying it's de-escalation he
doesn't want to Pat to get angry well
the Pap's standing next to him when he
asks for the capital police maybe but I
hear a knock on the door did you hear
the knock if you pull it back right
before he mentions the Capitol Police
here
four nights protect my wife no this is
San Francisco police Friday I I no I
understand
um
no it's before this
uh
he thinks everything's good I I've got a
problem but you can hear the terror in
his voice
so I go back it's earlier
uh he's just uh waiting for her to come
back because she's not going to be here
for a day so I guess left away
zero okay do you need to please fire a
medical for anything eight seconds uh I
I don't think so I don't think so
yeah why would he just say yes right
there why would he say I don't think so
yeah but then say are the capital police
around he might have closed walked into
a bathroom and closed the door when he
right before he mentions
what was that
but it could be I
think zero two twenty three and three
eight seconds yeah there's the uh
um I don't think someone's knocking I
think someone's putting something down
on the dresser maybe maybe this is like
right before he opens the doors like can
you please
because of this call they sent police
out later on yeah but I mean when he
says the are the Capitol Police around
and then he opens the door to let David
in something like that like maybe David
didn't hear him say that part
somehow
if David wasn't in the room with him and
he was on the phone with police he would
have said send the police now I need
help
so if David is in the room with him the
argument is that he didn't want to
agitate to pep but then he literally
says are the capital police around so
I'm wondering if he he was like David I
gotta go to the bathroom hold on we'll
figure this out he goes in the bathroom
close the door makes the call halfway
through right before he you hear him
knock on the door and he's like are the
Capitol Police around because that's the
knock and then he opens the door I
wouldn't he closed the door and say okay
yes please come yeah why would he just
lock the door doesn't make sense
this is what's frustrated me why
everyone is trying so hard to justify
Paul Pelosi is innocent and was actually
a victim when the call doesn't make
sense I'm justifying it because the pap
smashed his window to get into his house
and hit him in the head with a hammer
yeah
Paul Pelosi is drunk out of his mind and
doesn't make sense so it's like why why
why try and twist yourself into a
position to justify that Paul Pelosi's
call makes no sense
I mean a lot of people at first were
saying uh the lover thing right that was
exactly that was silly because if I mean
if he was looking for a gay lover he
he's rich and he's 80 you know he's in
San Francisco he wouldn't find a 300
pound fat loser like that he could find
like a 40 year old maybe he likes him
big maybe I don't know maybe he's got to
finish for it yeah people got no
judgment exactly I was looking for Nancy
for sure the way he said he's here
looking for my wife like he says it all
diplines he's definitely looking for
Nancy yeah that's what he says so he's
trying to give David some hope like hey
maybe let's let's let's play through the
call they're usually here at the house
protecting my wife
um no this is San Francisco police
I I no I understand
um
what do you think that's aware we got
pepperoni too
uh
it means everything's good I I've got a
problem but he thinks everything's good
okay
think about that call us back if you
need some help or whatever she said
change your mind or if you change your
mind no no this this filament just uh
came into the house uh and he wants to
wait here for my wife to come home and
so uh
do you know who the person is
no I don't know who he is he uh
what is your address okay this is just
weird like that sounds like a lie he
probably knows who he is it sounds like
a lie because he's like he's not gonna
have to do anything the dude's standing
next to him he's literally asking to Pap
what he thinks but then telling the
police to pap says don't do anything
doesn't make sense it does what doesn't
make sense is we can say Pelosi's drunk
but the pap is standing next to him
being like don't you call the police
oh tell them my name's David what yeah I
think the cap expected that this phone
call was going to result in Nancy coming
over
uh 26 40. that's what I was saying like
that he was humoring him he's making him
thinking
Friday anyway
okay okay who what's the gentleman's
name
he can hear the dispatcher
she said what's his name he immediately
responded David I can't hear what
they're saying yeah he can hear the
dispatcher his name is David
okay and who is David I I don't know
right what's that I'm a friend of theirs
yeah he says he's a friend but
you don't know who he is
right there you're sending squad cars
okay yeah immediately like this is an
emergency
dispatcher yeah that's all so he didn't
know David that's all the dispatch you
need to hear like you don't know who he
is like
I mean look I'm not gonna sit here and
pretend that everybody is smart enough
to break this down but if I was a 911
dispatcher 911 dispatcher and a guy
called and said yes some guy just came
into my house and uh he's he's he's uh
wait here for my wife I'd be like what's
your address instantly what's your
address and then I'd call and be like we
got a report of someone I drink
someone's house you guys want to go
check it out I'll keep him on the phone
and try and figure out what's going on
but this lady
this 911 dispatcher is just like well
okay I guess like are you kidding you
get these problems back if you need them
yeah do you guys ever hear that dispatch
call where the guy got stabbed and he
called 9-1-1 he's like I've been stabbed
I'm bleeding out and she's like calm
where are you and yeah call we are
really where are you at he's like I
don't know or something she's like is
that good confrontation with him there
was one where two kids got shot in a
drive-by
and then two young guys young adults man
like 20 years old and they call and
they're like help oh I've been shot and
she goes calm down where he's like I'm
dying I'm I'm here I'm here's the
address and she goes if you keep talking
to me like that that's what it was yeah
that's what I'm thinking about like a
lot of these 911 dispatchers like RMV
employees they're the grumpiest people
like dude I'm in crisis aren't you used
to this like every person a college is
in crisis have you never dealt with a
crazy person before you're like I'm
sorry I don't talk to people unless you
talk to me in common voice you're 9-1-1
probably like compassion fatigue you
know they do this all the time it could
be them like being at the point where
like they've just done it all day they
don't know if there could be people that
come into the same day that were
pranking them the whole time you never
know you know what I mean yeah
there are a ton of people who call in
insanely hysterical over something that
like if you're the 911 dispatcher starts
to feel small in comparison like the
next person calls it with the murder
person for that calls you because
someone bumped their car look at the
Veritas video from yesterday the guy
called the cops for that for asking them
questions the cops are like sorry to
interruptly no sir
um I I think the word thing to me is
that like she's like well so calls back
and Paul's like no I have a problem I
don't want him to be here like I can't
explain the beginning of the call it is
weird no matter how you look at it I
personally tend to lean towards like
yeah I think it does seem like he's
trying to like alert someone and I still
have the Instinct that he maybe tried to
get a hold of capital police first and
it didn't I I just gotta I gotta I gotta
stop real quick
take everything to consideration with
the 9-1-1 call and then take into
consideration that he answers the door
with the police holding a beverage yeah
maybe it's water that he won't put down
that he won't put down and when the pap
twists the hammer out of his hand
he still won't drop his drink to try and
stop the hammer alcoholism good drink
maybe that's some Alpha thing he's like
trying to establish like yo I'm in
control here I don't know six thousand
dollar whiskey he's like it's not like
it's not I'm not dropping he's not
buying the cheap stuff no wow I mean
Nancy's got that 20 ice cream or
whatever you know in her fridge remember
that maybe Paul felt like the cops are
gonna get this guy off of me so let's
just move on some people in a crisis
situation are good at staying calm and
trying to talk The person down stuff
like that but like I I don't know that
Paul Pelosi is maybe he is but to then
walk around with your your like night
cap is very strange I'm gonna play this
there's only a few more seconds
okay
thank you okay bye
um I don't understand here I don't
understand why considering we heard all
of that he didn't say to David
if you want me to call Nancy I can I can
call the the the the the the people who
who drive around take care of it the
police are saying I'll call him and let
him know and tell him to bring her over
he would have believed it probably I
mean he literally said on the phone I
want Capital police
I don't understand why he said is the
are the Capitol Police there instead of
just saying
are like you're the police will do yeah
right any police will do he was probably
panicking as he was drunk and and not
used to this kind of thing because it
just didn't a lot of it was just kind of
desperate like Capitol Police when he's
on the San Francisco 9-1-1 call and he
asked for Capital police that's a that's
a weird desperation that's why I want to
know like why is he like I need Capital
police like if you're drunk and you're
in an emergency even if you're managing
to stay weirdly calm like as soon as you
get any kind of police wouldn't you be
like yes yes like to me it's it's
interesting that he is specifically like
I I don't know that I want to talk to
you but I definitely want to talk to
Capital it's also possible that Capitol
Police has a contingent in San Francisco
watching the Pelosi's house that are in
touch with the police department but 911
dispatcher didn't know that uh Philip R
super chatted that he was trying to
speak in code telling her that he was
Pelosi's husband I do agree with that he
says you know he's waiting for my wife
Nancy Pelosi and it's just like the
funny thing about that is like my guy
nobody knows who that is go nobody knows
that is I I will I will I will we should
maybe pelosias nobody knows who Nancy
Pelosi is I think there are tons of
people who couldn't name this people
what I'd be willing to bet you're in the
news yeah go to times go to Times Square
and I will give you 10 bucks for every
person who says they know Nancy Pelosi
is yeah what percentage of the country
do you think knows who Nancy Pelosi is
12 adults adults oh yeah 12 12 that's it
yep what yeah I was thinking that today
one of the most identifiable have you
ever watched fleka's videos I have where
he goes on the street and asks them
basic questions like what name a country
that starts with the letter U and they
go uh I don't know it's like United
States of America another question oh
come on do you think uh you think I was
thinking last night oh what's it no go
ahead oh we're in an Echo chain oh I'm
in an echo chamber even though I'm
trying to be open mind I call I texted
my buddy out in L.A and I was like what
do people in your Zone think about
Ukraine do they want an escalation
because I'm in kind of like a
Libertarian conservative Echo chamber
and everybody wants out of there they
want the US not involved and so he
messaged back he's like we want peace we
want Russia to not be invading and it's
like man I just I still have like
portals to people in other Echo Chambers
but we are and even social media is
intensifying that yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time